This is a button. You click it, the page
updates, fresh data straight from the
server, no reload.
Now, here's the strange part. There is
no JavaScript here. None that you wrote.
The whole thing is one HTML attribute.
To do that same little update the modern
way, you'd reach for React, a component,
a piece of state, a fetch call, a JSON
endpoint on the server, and a re-render
to stitch it all back together. That is
a lot of moving parts for one number on
a screen. HTMX throws all of it out. And
the secret is almost insultingly simple.
Let plain HTML talk to the server
directly and swap in whatever HTML comes
back. Dumb, and it works. So, here's the
plan. First, the one idea underneath it
and why the way we've been doing this is
stranger than it looks. Then the whole
thing in four attributes, because that's
genuinely all there is. And then the
honest catch, because there's always
one, and HTMX fans are terrible at
admitting it. Start with a restaurant,
because this whole argument is a kitchen
argument. You order a dish. The kitchen
cooks it, plates it, and a runner brings
it to your table. That's the web
originally. The server assembled a
finished page and handed it over. Now,
here's what a modern single-page app
does instead. You order, and the kitchen
sends out raw ingredients in labeled
containers. That's your JSON. Then you
assemble the dish yourself at your table
with your own equipment, which you had
to install first. That's React. So, now
there are two kitchens. One on the
server that knows what a dish is, and
one in the browser that has to be told
again.
And you keep a copy of the menu in both
places, and you write an API forever
just to keep the two copies agreeing.
HTMX looks at that and asks the obvious
question.
Why don't we just send the plate?
That's it. That's the whole product.
It's about 16 kilobytes, zero
dependencies, written in plain
JavaScript you never touch. And it was
made by Carson Gross, a computer science
professor in Montana, not a
trillion-dollar framework team. Here's
the loop. You add HX get to an element.
Click it, HTMX fires an HTTP request for
you. The server sends back a chunk of
HTML. HTMX drops that HTML into the
page. Request, response, swap, done. And
four attributes cover essentially
everything. HX post says where to send
it. HX target says which element on the
page should change. HX swap says how,
replace the insides, the whole element,
or just append. And HX trigger says
when, a click, a form change, a key
press, a debounce, so it waits until you
stop typing, or a timer that fires every
couple of seconds for a live dashboard.
That's four attributes, not 400 lines.
And notice what just got unlocked,
because HTML never let you do any of
this. Any element can make a request,
not just links and forms, a div, a table
row, an input. Any event can trigger it,
not just clicks. Every HTTP verb works,
not just the two that forms gave you. So
a delete button sends an actual HTTP
delete. The server removes the record,
returns nothing, and HTMX swaps that row
out of existence. No state to reconcile,
nothing to sync. The row is just gone.
Here's the demo that sold a whole
generation, an input with HX get firing
on key up. You type HTMX queries the
server. The server returns table rows as
HTML, and they swap into the results.
Live search, three lines, no API to
build. And that phrase no API to build
is the part that should stop you. Your
back end isn't returning data anymore,
it's returning finished plates, which
means it can be literally anything.
Python, Ruby, Go, PHP, Node. If it can
return HTML, it speaks HTMX. The
community even has a name for the stack,
HAL,
hypermedia on whatever you'd like. It
handles the fiddly parts, too.
An out-of-band swap lets one response
patch two places at once, the thing you
clicked and the cart count up in the
corner. One request, two updates, zero
glue code. HX E boost quietly upgrades
ordinary links and forms into background
requests, so you get that smooth, no
flash, single-page feel on a site that's
really just plain HTML pages underneath.
And a loading spinner while the request
is in flight is one attribute, not a
piece of state you hand-wire. Now, the
receipts, because this isn't a thought
experiment. HTMX is around 16 KB.
React plus React DOM, just the core,
before your app exists, is roughly 45.
A real single-page app ships hundreds of
kilobytes before it shows you anything.
And a company called Context rewrote
their React app in HTMX and reported 67%
less code, JavaScript dependencies down
from 255 to 9, and build times down
nearly 90%. That's not a benchmark.
That's a team deleting a second kitchen.
Underneath all of this is an old idea
with a fancy name, hypermedia. The
server doesn't just send data, it sends
the next available actions baked into
the HTML.
The page carries the state of your
application, and here's the part that
breaks people. This is REST, the real
REST, the way Roy Fielding actually
defined it. Somewhere along the line,
the word got hijacked to mean a JSON
API. HTMX is quietly just going back. It
also restores something we lost without
noticing,
locality of behavior.
Look at the element and you can see
exactly what it does right there in the
markup. No hunting through a dozen files
to trace one click. Now, the honest
catch, and let me be fair to React
first, because HTMX people usually
aren't. React is not a mistake, and it
didn't win by accident. There is a real
category of application where you
genuinely do need a kitchen at your
table. A spreadsheet like Google Sheets
where 1,000 cells recalculate the
instant you type, a map you drag in real
time, anything that has to work offline,
anything with thousands of
interdependent widgets that must react
instantly, locally, with no round trip.
Send a request to the server for each of
those interactions and your app feels
broken because it is. That's React's
home turf and it isn't close. If you're
building a deeply interactive client
application, use React. That's the thing
it's brilliant at. So, no, this isn't
React's funeral. The honest line is
narrower and more useful than the hype.
HTMX is for the other 90% of the web.
Forms, dashboards, content, CRUD. The
boring stuff that is secretly almost
everything. And be clear-eyed about the
trade you're making. Every interaction
is a network round trip, so a flaky
connection feels worse than it would in
a client-side app. Your server does more
work on every click. And no JavaScript
is a little bit of marketing the moment
you want a drop-down, a toggle, or an
animation. You reach for a small partner
like alpine.js or hyperscript. Small
tools sprinkled where you need them
instead of one giant framework running
everything. That's still a much better
deal. It's just not zero. Four numbers
to walk away with. 16 KB against React's
45 before your app even starts. Four
attributes that cover nearly the whole
surface area.
255 dependencies down to nine in one
real rewrite. And one copy of your state
instead of two, which is where a whole
category of bug quietly disappears. Back
to the kitchen. For years, the
industry's answer to a slow, clunky web
was to build a second kitchen in the
browser. Staff it, ship it to every
visitor, and then write an API forever
to keep the two menus in sync.
HTMX's radical suggestion is that most
restaurants only ever needed the one and
a runner who brings out the plate. Maybe
the website was the framework all along.
If this made the modern web feel a
little less insane, subscribe. That's
the only thing I'm selling here. I'll
see you in the next one.